l'explosion d'un train à lac-mégantic
qui a fait 47 morts et une des pires
tragédies survenues au pays
guillaume bouchard a été surpris de voir
que certaines images de l'immense
brasier ont été utilisées pour illustrer
une explosion nucléaire à londres dans
la fiction
les voyageurs du temps diffusé sur
netflix juste les volutes de fumée la
traîne à la chaleur à ce propos on peut
faire ça ça se peut pas tout allait
vérifier bien rap nuage et j'ai compris
leur erreur
les voyageurs du temps est une série
télévisuelle de trois saisons l'émission
est réalisée par une maison de
production de toronto peacock ali
entertainment qui a décliné notre
demande d'entrevue par courriel
l'entreprise fait son mea culpa et écrit
qu'elle n'aurait pas dû utiliser ces
images acheté chez un fournisseur
d'archivés présidente écrit nous
n'étions pas au courant de la provenance
de ces images nous nous excusons
sincèrement et nous n'avions aucunement
l'intention de manquer de respect à la
suite des événements tragiques de 2013
netflix a aussi refusé notre demande
d'entrevue mais s'engage à mettre sur sa
plateforme une nouvelle version de
l'épisode sans les images de lac
mégantic
la nouvelle fait réagir à lac mégantic
il ya une partie qui me choque
il ya une partie que je comprends il ya
une partie qui me choque je vous ce
trouble troublant parce que ça nous
ramène ou un des douleurs alors qu'on
utilise dans un film de fiction où on
veut illustrer une explosion la mairesse
de lac-mégantic applaudi la décision
d'enlever les images et la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il est le producteur
aurait agi rapidement il faut dénoncer
ce genre de pratique là parce que
effectivement je pense que ça manque de
respect pour les familles endeuillées
entre autres qui peuvent avoir envie un
dimanche d'écouter une série même si la
tragédie de lac-mégantic n'a été utilisé
que quelques secondes dans les voyageurs
du temps guillaume bouchard souhaite que
netflix et ses producteurs soient plus
vigilants
je pense pas que c'est là des mauvaises
intentions le monde du divertissement
prend de plus en plus de place ben ça
veut pas dire que parce que maintenant
de produire en quantité ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut laisser la qualité ici louis
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal